[Applause]
well oh hello Uncle mil I hope you don't
mind my borrowing this book from your
Des oh not of all my boy a sympathetic B
at everybody to school that's one of my
favorites now what would you like to do
today
well I guess I was waiting for the right
[Music]
moment
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
the
free
[Music]
freee of the of the out of the out of
the out of the fre out of the fre out of
the out of the out of the out of the out
of the out of
[Music]
the what would you like to do
today fun making C my eye on some
property in
that how are you going to earn all
money I could start by Bing you $5 30
seconds your face will move
okay all right
I'll just to give you a
Lon oh that was a really good that one
needs a name dude